parti pour ce live spécial français à la
draft de 20 de la draft dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi qui sera à suivre soit
chez first in avec alan et manu en
plateau soit chez bing vous pouvez faire
un double écran et bim avec le grand
rond dans le roi sera également présent
pour nous représenter sur le plateau de
bim sport et oui évidemment mais mais
mais mais mais en attendant on a déjà
des comparaisons exceptionnelle dans le
chat pour le retour de nico comment
vas-tu niko
ça va très bien bonjour à tout le monde
effectivement si les belges avaient
seulement se montre et il ay là il a mis
les lunettes adéquates
complètement le style du professeur
parce que ça faisait longtemps qu'il
n'était pas venu nous donner ces
lumières sûr et prospère on va parler
des français on a aussi parlé des
internationaux le titre était trop long
ni les français ce qui va nous
intéresser d'abord mai mais ya pas mal
de choses à dire sur des prospects
internationaux au premier tour surtout
au second à se mentir la cuvée
internationale n'est pas non plus
extraordinaire cette année
la génération d'après a des cheveux
n'est pas encore de lunettes
luca qui fait partie il peut vous est
pris à un petit article sur sur
envergure est qui et qui se cache
également comment vas-tu luca ça va très
bien et toi content d'être avec vous
pour ce premier live bien d'un en
tauride fait plaisir exactement première
première apparition
ça fait très plaisir de t'avoir on va
avoir des avis différents sur les écrous
très français et internationaux et puis
alan
tous les trois vous avez vous avez un
peu parcouru ça va toi moi je dors pas
trop comme tous deux jours du choc mais
cela serveurs nous faut pas dormir donc
là on dormira peut-être au mois de
juillet non-couleur pascal du
championnat
verra on fait des siestes des micro
sieste
soit vous avez pour expliquer nico vous
avez quand même un peu on peut voyager
ensemble pour aller
en live les prospects dont on va parler
pas tous mais
c'est vrai que j'avais l'habitude de
parcourir l'europe en étant quasiment le
seul français ou de croiser des agents
français est là depuis depuis quelques
années depuis depuis en tout cas cette
année c'était avec alan manu luca
c'était l'occasion voilà de voyages et
de voyager ensemble c'était c'était
super agréable et puis ben ça nous ça
nous a offert des vrais bons débat sur
la date de cette année mais surtout sur
les tic novart absolument puisque c'est
surtout des prospects plus jeunes dont
on parlera encore plus tard qu'ils sont
là sur sur les tournois
on commence donc on va dire dans l'ordre
des mots qu un premier crime mais qui
donne une certaine température quand
même
pour cette grappe 2022 je parle d'eux
athlétique dit espionne surtout le
prospect international qui est classé le
plus beau
alors je parle pas de dyson daniels qui
jouait avec ladji midnight puisque c'est
lui qui bloque la scène plus haut mais
vraiment de voir jouer à l'étranger et
donc on va parler du français a parlé
d'ousmane dieng qui est vu lottery pick
est là alan c'est l'histoire de deux
saisons quand même pour ramener à ceux
qui n'ont pas dû jouer du tout est
convenu au moment où on en parlait
dernière à prendre par les clubs pour on
reparlait ça a suivi une courbe de
performance chez
moi complètement là je pense qu'il ait
toujours il faut rappeler que sa
carrière a été vraiment influé par le
cos vide parce que le coved arrive il
est essentielle est joué donc en nm1
qu'en troisième division française avec
l'insep donc il sera deuxième siècle à
cause du cobicistat eu pas mal de soucis
sur sur sa donc sur le développement
pour toute la génération d'ailleurs 2003
française avec de l'insep avec pas mal
de soucis là dessus il part en australie
donc programme une extase les programmes
cavic avait reçu l'âme et lobo les
rejets hampton terrain de ferguson avant
et qui va recevoir rien à rupert l'autre
français l'an prochain donc au breakers
et c'est une particularité parce qu'il
est arrivé deux prospects sont arrivés
c'était quasiment la première fois deux
étaient dans la même équipe ont fait 2
avec des ambitions de draft étaient dans
la mine actifs et donc ousmane a moins
bien débuter l'année ça se pourrait que
c'est vraiment un gros changement dans
son entrée dans le monde professionnel
il y avait du mal même à rester sur le
terrain et puis ou ferme jours de gagner
on a vu un joueur qui par son tir part
sont pelés making pour sa taille savait
se rendre utile même en n'étant pas
l'option de mireuil nous le meilleur
joueur passe quelque chose importante
pension future nba parce que même si il
l'était en ligne c'est qu'il était avec
les équipes de france de jeunes parfois
c'est dire le leader pollen leur numéro
un de l'équipe en une vieille ce sera
sûrement pas le cadre il a montré qu'il
pouvait développer des attributs ans que
secondaire un peu un peu un peu même
tertiaire et nous tire la passe le jeu
on peut sans ballon ce qui fait qu'avec
son physique avec sa jeunesse avec le
potentiel qu'il a montrées wailly sa fin
de saison est vraiment venu
l'arrêter c'est mieux que de faire
l'inversé en fait pour l'adar parce que
tu finit bien donc un peu le mot pour
mot mans devront la balade gauche guy
daigle est sorti guidy qui avait surfé
des triples doubles mois de mars marque
de vêtements
juste que je rebondis là-dessus allant
de la parole à l'uqam
ousmane dieng tu l'a 10 il est vu comme
un gars qui a le ballon entre les mains
mais il n'aura pas l'année prochaine il
n'aura sûrement peut-être pas l'année
d'après est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui va le faire baisser va faire baisser
sa cote à tes yeux dans notre dans notre
big board la 17e ce qui est ce qui est
bien mais mais on pourrait se dire si on
attend si on draft un gars qui peut
avoir le ballon le draft plus haut que
ça donc
est-ce qu'il n'arrive pas trop tôt
qu'est ce que tu penses de ça
complètement c'est un peu la question
moi je pense pas que même à terme ça
peut être un créateur de balle en main
efficace d'une attaque nba et c'est pas
grave parce que ça c'est l'élite qui
fait ça avant une billets mais en fait
je pense que la combinaison pelé making
pour sa taille sir pour sa taille
qu'est-ce qu'il soit fin d'année fait
que c'est quand même rare d'avoir un
procès aussi jeune à cette taille là qui
peut faire du climat jean gay peut tirer
en catch and shoot c'est ça qui rend le
profil si intéressant et en plus de ça
ceux qui croient vraiment en lui pense
que lui il peut avoir la voile et donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils vont le draft et
plus haut c'est pour ça qu'ils vont la
voir je pense de leur deuxième partie de
la loterie si on pense qu' il n'aura
peut-être jamais les capacités pour être
ce premier ou deuxième porteur de balle
là où il peut être qu'il va y voir un
petit peu plus descendre je pense qu'il
ya plus un plancher qu'on pouvait penser
vous pensez que le plancher et et
baghlan fait à sa taille tirer comme ça
défendre avec sa tête comme ça et
pouvoir être fonctionnel en termes de
création sam est un bon plancher avec le
plafond qui est celui de la capacité à
créer ballan non ça on verra on verra
dans les années une bille on verra la
summer league on verra comment ça se
passe on parlait avec hugues dans le
podcast sur les ldd ce rôle de
connecteurs un petit peu à la france
wagner c'est bon orlando alors
bien plus haut qu espéré
tout cas est ce que pour toi il peut
être un porteur de balle
primaire ou secondaire et ce qu'il en a
les atouts que ce soit au niveau du
lander de la vision de jeu de la force
aussi secret
pour moi il pourra pas être un porteur
de balle primaire en nba
peut-être pas du tout un secondaire en
tout cas quand il arrivera parce que
physiquement pour l'instant il peut pas
il peut pas tenir dans le combat
mais il a une formation c'est assez
impressionnant il a une formation meneur
il peut faire des passes passe en course
il n'a pas besoin d'être à l'arrêt pour
faire jouer les autres et ouais mais
comme le disait alan pense qu'on verra
beaucoup dans un contexte sans la balle
qui nous a montré vers la fin de saison
ou
avec les braqueurs ce début de l'année
il avait beaucoup plu ce rôle de prix
marie bauer qui au final lui allait pas
forcément parce que le un peu du mal
physiquement a créé des actes et des
actions pour lui la situation est dans à
partir du milieu de saison en partie
février il a vraiment pris ce rôle ou
simple plus oublier parfois il décale
aux postes 3 et c est une même si les
chiffres ne sont pas à sa gestuelle
montrent que dans les années qui qui qui
viennent ça pourrait devenir un shooter
liszt en nba en début d'année on avait
tissé prades dans l'année brad qui me
disait il est à deux ans d'être prêt
et est ce que cette accélération est
toujours vrai et si oui qu'est-ce qui
est le plus urgent à travailler
pour moi c'est le physique et au début
de l'année y avait encore beaucoup plus
de choses à travailler
j'étais d'accord avec les deux ans pour
être prêt mais là vers la fin de saison
je pense que pas dès l'année prochaine
monde est là dès la fin de saison quand
son équipe aura plus rien à jouer je
pense qu'il n'entrera des bonnes choses
il pour avoir du temps de jeu je pense
que dès l'année prochaine il pourra
gratter des minutes en nba alors que la
saison j'étais un peu sceptique je le
voyais faire un nom en jig entièrement
sans passer par sans faire un match nba
meiway physiquement il ya du boulot à
faire mais ça c'est pas nouveau mais il
a montré vraiment des bonnes qualités et
je pense que les les son shoot se
développera au fur et à mesure des mois
c'est ce sera une question de mois pour
développer son tir et il pourra navigue
raté beaucoup de minutes jusqu'à ce
qu'on le pense la saison prochaine alex
là dessus il ya un avant et après
décembre
dans le sens où vraiment sur le début de
saison avec tout l'amour que je lui
porte je le voyais jouer je me dis ouah
on dirait vraiment une girafe un bébé
girafe qui est sur le terrain et kiki il
sait pas comment se déplacer il sait pas
trop ce qui se passe ça faisait un peu
peur et puis il a eu un vrai il ya eu un
vrai déclic et je pense en terme de
confiance plus qu'autre chose les échos
sont c'est un bosseur il a une bonne
mentalité mais il ya vraiment là sans en
dire trop en tout cas il ya eu un avant
et après autour de mode d'essen ouest
donc ça rassure aussi sur la capacité de
travail
c'est le message que tu fais pas c'est
là la question du chat de ta 67 elle est
pour toi allez les filles de comparer le
profil d'ousmane dieng à celui de jayden
mcdaniels
c'est intéressant parce que c'est des
joueurs wii qui avait dont on pensait
qu'il serait les stars même balle en
moins dans les catégories plus inférieur
et que et qui pare des attributs
secondaire de leur jeu peuvent se muer
en parfait complément parfait 4e 5e
meilleur joueur d'une bonne équipe si
tout se passe bien pour mcdaniels ça a
été la longueur défensive la capacité
est un excellent défenseur des diamètres
ces trois points en cash and shoot je
pense que pour ousmane ce sera un peu la
même chose ce sera d'être capable de ne
pas tuer ton spacing d'un capable de
jouer limite un peu poste 4 3 4 en amont
sur sur offensivement mais wayne et de
faire les ne pas faire d'erreur
défensivement je pense que c'est c'est
une bonne
c'est assez intéressant de voir ce
devoir c'est pas grave tout s'indigne ne
vient pas paul georges où les coups ce
genre de joueurs lassés il peut aussi
être excellent extrêmement utile et
quand une longue carrière dans un rôle
de complément et un rôle qui vaut une
place en fin de note rifains défendent
et dix autres exemples de joueurs qui
ont eu un développement en arrivant un
peu avec ce manque de force il y est
donc mal à vous gratter des minutes
assez vite mais qu'ils ont eue en
développement à la fois physiques et
techniques ont permis d'avoir une belle
carrière en fuite
bien sûr il faudrait que je trouve
j'ai en train d'essayer de réfléchir
j'entre à un pc de réfléchir je vais te
dire sur
david ou dix ans nico batum qui a été
vraiment de cette comparaison luca
milito
sport par rapport au standing ouais je
trouve que
c'est difficilement comparables en
sachant que nico batum quand dans mes
souvenirs en ce que j'ai j'étais pas
très très violent
mais il n'avait pas cette capacité à se
déplacer ou spending par flash quand ils
se déplacent sur le terrain aux
pressions de tu peux pas taper t'as pas
l'impression de voir un mec de deux
médecins que se déplace sur bien
ce que batum avait déjà cette faculté à
se déplacer mais par contre pas avec la
balle bonne pour moi ousmane est
beaucoup plus porteur de balle lundi
kobato après peut-être que au final dans
5 ans 10 ans ils auront peut-être le
même rôle mais dans le parcours le papa
est vraiment différent c'est ça c'est un
rôle de délai qui peut passer de
rillieux shooter un niveau moyen et une
bille et c'est important parce que c'est
des pointes chose qui est extrêmement
trouvable
il ya aussi autre jeanine hobby mais en
fait il est plus parce qu'il avait des
problèmes de blessure et donc il pouvait
pas jouer mais l'espagne est costaud est
beaucoup plus costaud mais aussi des
pépins d'épreuves physiques qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas jouer dans cette première
trop dans les premières années il a
vraiment réussi à se développer en fait
vous le dire c'est que c'est un aîné
ousmane dieng un grand il est même et
donc c'est une denrée rare et plutôt est
plutôt chère donc c'est pour ça aussi je
pense que il va se faire a draftés assez
haut
est ce que quelqu'un a quelque chose à
ajouter sur ousmane dieng est ce que
pour vous
ça vous paraît cohérent qui soient
annoncées loterie top-20 tape dans chez
nous
oui sur potentiellement sur
l'âge sur le rapport taille aps les
making pari foot fait rare et on trouve
pas ça partout
il vient et c'est rare
de voir un joueur de cette taille
initiés de pick and roll et réussir à
servir le l'intérieur et c'est vraiment
dans moir il aura d'ailleurs intérieur
en nba cares il avait convaincu que
c'est un profil alors après sur la
production par rapport aux autres qui
sont arrivés
à l'anneau je parlais de georges didi
qui arrivait de nguyen qui avait privé
au même âge on arrive avec une
production déjà plus importante avec des
soucis aussi
défensive qu'il a toujours entièrement
gones et on tire pareillement
la mélodie guide est un peu des ovnis
faut pas trop les comparer avec ceux qui
vont à une biya je pense à l'argent
tonnes c'est déjà plus un devoir quitter
dans une rotation au breakers d'ailleurs
les braqueurs sont vraiment un fond dans
le programme next arzens donc
mais oui ça sera pas il n'aura pas le
même d'ailleurs il y sera pas top 6
comme au jazz idées comme la meilleure
ball donc il ya moins trouvé sur ça mais
il a aussi prouvé comme l'a dit nicolas
cas
des améliorations dans la saison
d'éléments de son jeu qui vont être clé
pour son futur ça je trouve aussi
intéressant
on va passer à son cou
cette année
qui ne jouait pas en 2001
juste à prendre
hugo b sont donc
qui a fait le grand saut
de prouver à une bielle alors déjà nous
pas on nous pose souvent la question à
savoir ce que tu en penses la
comparaison entre les deux championnats
au bn dit elle
je trouve que en regardant les matchs de
nba que que j'ai regardé je regardais
principalement besson il est digne mais
je trouve que le championnat pro b à une
partie quand même un peu plus brouillon
la démarche de pro b où vraiment cesser
purement ce purement physique sans
vraiment avoir un grand niveau
robin hood création et je trouve que
dans la nba il ya vraiment deux est
vraiment tout et est rien on va dire il
ya des matches où on peut avoir des
grosses affiches des des impacts en
physiquement mais comme il ya des
matches c'est vraiment pour moi c'est
des championnats similaire mais le
championnat une bière légèrement au
dessus mais physiquement la pro b c pour
moi c'est plus physique aujourd'hui la
première fois la comparaison que je
donne avant de laisser parler alan pour
moi c'est ça ressemble beaucoup au
championnat allemand dans le sens où
c'est moins athlétiques que le
championnat français aux plaines biais
sa défense peut-être un peu moins bien
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont un
cliché en ce moment à ça défend pas du
tout si ça défend sa défense moins qu'en
france mais en ôtant le championnat
français un des championnats les plus
défensifs aussi en tout cas les plus les
plus compacts en les plus impactants
physiquement et donc défensivement mais
je faisais partie des gens qui qui
râlaient à chaque fois qu'un pro specie
ni en australie jusqu'à ce que je m'y
intéresse en fait
je sais que j'ai jeté beaucoup de
pierres à l'âne quand on parle pas et
mélo ball
et au final avec le recul il avait
raison
c'est pas un championnat intéressant
c'est un jeu très intéressant où on peut
se développer
je trouve que pour les prospects qui
sont déjà aboutis et physiquement ils
sont ils sont vraiment dans un dans un
cadre où ils peuvent ou ne peuvent
s'exprimer
denis dubé sont déjà oubliées
physiquement
à la nsa pardon je pensais à un joueur
dont on va parler plus tard mon ami
dr house
mais lui il est de là-bas
à l'année ce qui est ce qui s est ce que
c'était un bon choix y aller pour une
combustion plus pour nous battrons
oui je pense clairement on en parle tous
les deux comme des joueurs qui ont une
chance d'être drafté et pour hispania
qu'un jour je pense qui est sûr d'être
premier tour pour ça c'est un bon choix
gobé sont un joueur qui en l'espace de
nico c'est nous tout le monde il raconte
sur l'histoire du bo pulsions un joueur
qui n'était pas destinée selon les
entraîneurs qu'il avait dans les
catégories jeunes à avoir cette carrière
alors qu' un peu galéré mon championnat
espoir que vous ayez de faire un prêt en
pro b pour trouver du temps dieu qui
expose un point en pro b mais qui est
direct capitalise capitalise en allant
en allant en australie où là on va dire
offensivement dominé c'est à dire que
offensivement dans le shoot les making
donc porteur de bol de soi de la seconde
unis des pointures soit avec les
titulaires à côté et beaucoup de
turnover et payton steve acquis parti
pour aller jouer en europe
j'allais gérer un peu avec diagne aussi
pour savoir comment j'ai l'argent requis
génial à des attaques et un joueur qui a
montré aux scouts nba qui se déplace en
australie
qui était vraiment capable de mettre des
points dans un championnat professionnel
donc il y avait un vrai niveau de choc
making donc je pense qu'il a fait le bon
choix aussi parce que il aurait
peut-être plus appris peut-être dans un
vécu collectif en restant en france ou
en restant en europe a rejoint une coupe
d'europe mais en termes de cote il a je
pense qu'il l'a amélioré en a l'envié
justement je me fais une bonne passe
pour moi c'est même pas qu'il l'a
amélioré sa cote c'est que
même s'il avait fait une extrêmement
bonne saison en pro b avec saint-quentin
le côté tu penses que blessure peut être
drafté où ça faisait souvent sourire ça
faisait doigt est bon les gars faut pas
exagérer comme donc tous ces mêmes ça me
fait mal moi je suis je suis s'ils
pouvaient tous rester en france c'est le
premier heureux des prospects français
mais il y là
il a eu raison à 100% d'aller en
australie puisqu'il est maintenant il a
une vraie cote du coup c'est en fait
plus de l'image
ces démarches de ces deux là et c'est
quand même la mise en situation d'une
place au texte exactement c'est des
contextes quand même aussi je pense que
autant de respect il ya le fait que
sergio pena qui n'est pas douillet pas
de descente où il n'ya pas de près du
train pression du résultat les braqueurs
c'est la pire équipe et personnes trop
mais c'est en avant parfois quand on
parle de besoin et digne mais pareil
pour la meinau c'était la pire m'est
donc cette pression de la descente fait
que bon ben on donne beaucoup les clés
du camion aux jeunes quoi
luca pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
hugo besson c'est quoi ça sa clé
d'entrée en nba pourquoi on en parle
et c'est clairement tiercé c'est un
shooteur c'est un shooter est dit malgré
que son pourcentage ça va ça m'a étonné
de voir son pourcentage aussi bas que
dans un contexte où ils font beaucoup de
shoots à trois points transition mais
pour moi ça à clef d'entrée et ça
s'appelait de titi l'aidera à se
maintenir ses paires max os c'est un
score naturel qui pourra rentrer à voir
son temps de jeu 10 10 12 minutes et est
rentré ce corps est directement de
s'inscrire c'est naturel faites ce que
vous voulez dans le chat ne veux pas
savoir
qu'est-ce que
alan juste pour revenir sur la summer
league
il a montré encore des belles lacunes
défensives face à des prospects qui à
qui m comparé aux serments puisqu'ils
sont candidats aussi le combat une chose
à dire que le sprinter n'est pas le
combat
à quel crédit accorder à ça
je pense qu'il faut quand même accordé
un certaine forme de crédit parce que
les profil athlétique qu'il a affronté
là c'était mieux ce qu'il avait vu une
bielle et ça mais ça sera quand même
moins bien que ce qui va affronter une
bille et donc il faut quand même donner
du créatif dans la toujours un peu dit
je pense que du beau mais sont
physiquement défensivement ça pouvait
compliquer et c'est pour ça parce que le
braille la lite le cuit il a offensif
donc tout le monde peut penser que ça
peut être un excellent d'un club preneur
ou troisième garde d'une attaque nba qui
apporte tout de suite de l' attaque
quand ils arrivent sur le terrain et
c'est vrai qu'on a vu que défensivement
dans la navigation coins du terrain sur
le premier pas il avait du mal à tenir
certains porteurs de balle je dis moi je
crois que c'était des rentes si brawn
premiers pas là elle vraiment par
famille est mis à mal ouais donc oui il
faut il faut il faut quand même tenir
compte puisque tout contexte apporte une
information qui intéresse entre pas tout
faux pas se faire que son avis sur ça
mais c'est s'aider contexte
international espoirs pro b nico ou
elton contrediront pas je pense qu'il y
aura une veillée à part affronter des
porteurs de balle comme une affrontés
lors de ce combat indra des prospects 21
22 ans qui quittent la zone égal à
naples il a jaugé la zone des gains et
ça s'est pas très bien passé pour le
vois tu vois une paire limites
défensives a même s'ils progressent ce
muscle
est ce que c'est un joueur à qui on va
pouvoir donner des minutes importante
des minutes importante est-ce que tu
confierait des minutes importante à
desjardins claque ça
bat dans ce cas là tu peux en donner les
commerçants pour moi je le vois vraiment
je parle pas de talent ou de niveau je
parle de rôle pour moi ça va vraiment
être un dynamiteur de sortie de banc à
prendre cinq tirs en une minute et puis
aller se rasseoir après si ça rentre pas
et si ça rentre rester le temps le temps
que son équipe a besoin je dois vraiment
vraiment dans ce rôle là puis il ya un
mot qu'on a pas citées depuis cinq
minutes comparé aux pressions des
cojones
lescornez comme ça c'est c'est sa
deuxième qualité après son tir c'est que
il ya un côté fou fou ya un côté peu
importe qui est en face quoi je vais
jouer mon jeu et ça c'est parfait pour
elle vient
d'ailleurs c'est un joueur qui s'est
construit on parlait comme ça de bonny
island l'année dernière c'est un joueur
très gros oui en étant moins fort
physiquement que les adversaires compter
les rumeurs cas jamais été mis en avant
aussi la génération 2001 génération
dorée un peu en france oui parce que
soit son poste avec kilian est et au mal
et donc malgré mac match gauzins cruzol
benitez cazalon il n'a jamais été démis
là et là aujourd'hui il est devant la
plupart de ces jours là
avec une chance d'être drafté dans son
développement et voilà donc c'est aussi
un jour je pense que j'en ai un peu pour
un à [ __ ] on va pas se mentir qui est
qui veut juger au basket et mettez
panique au bout d'un moment tu mets des
paniers avec un gros gros bras ça marche
en aiguille carlos ghosn du basket ball
c'est m exactement mais c'est très rare
chez nous les français d'avoir déjoué
avec des mentalités comme ça oui que
coup ci c'est
appréciable
que design tout à l'heure par rapport au
combat
ses aspects créé pourquoi malgré un beau
coup un beau combat il a perdu de la
côte finale en que les scouts ont pu
voir ce gros manques défensifs sur les
bonnes leur icône au final il ne pouvait
pas défendre des volants de leurs
prospects biais et donc je pense que
c'est le combat il a vraiment mis en
évidence quand il me disait tout à
l'heure niko ça défend pas énormément
une aile défensif n'était pas autant mis
en valeur que aux compagnies
alors après il a pour lui une taille
correcte par rapport à dire qu'il va
pouvoir
nico je te vois qui sait il va peut-être
pouvoir se cacher sur des mecs de taille
moyenne qui compte pas trop ce qu'ils
offensif clair ils sont pareils en tout
cas
c'est bien
pour bondir sur les pourcentages
look a parlé des pourcentages c'est vrai
les cas 30% à 3 points et on le présente
comme un gros shooteur beaucoup de tirs
ont sorti deux rives et ira loin
compliqué et un jean un peu de séries
sur cette année avant une bielle et
quand il était dans son dans son
quotidien dans son match dans son
adresse comme l'a dit nico sont
prophétiques dordain clarkson type tiger
heroes ce genre de jour là c'est un
joueur qui sait un vrai il peut marquer
beaucoup de points en très peu de temps
donc ça ça peut être quelque chose que
les équipes vont aller chercher au
deuxième tour en attendant voilà on a
besoin d'un type un joueur de ce type
les rangs sorti du banc à développer on
nous demande d envoyer vos questions
dans le chat et bonjour à ceux qui
arrivent on nous demande quel est son
plafond je vous laisse réfléchir à ça et
pendant ce temps j'ai introduit dont la
loom notre invité pour parler du gobé
sont ensuite de moussa diabaté c'est
gabriel pour tel vous salue gabriel
d'allegra ça va ça va très bien vie
bascule
qu'est ce que tu as à nous dire sur une
ovation à ce que tu as des questions est
ce que tu as des remarques qu'est ce que
pour toi c'est une surprise on se
retrouve à parler de lui comme mon
français n'est
pas une surprise de oui et non oui et
non pourquoi parce que non ça fait deux
ans quand même que ça reste quand même
conséquente douzaine de saisons avant la
draft qu'il est qui peut parler lui
quand les vacances billets
sa saison autant son début de saison 1
sur saint quentin pouvait de
surprenantes ce qui était surprenant
c'est qu'il a été capable d'être
consistant tout au long de la saison
dans une équipe compétitive cette saison
c'est un peu différent
je vous écoute et un peu lassé dernière
minute moi j'ai l'impression avec hugo
besson pour faire un comparatif qu'on a
un joueur qui il me fait penser à marine
joannes pour le pour sa capacité à
marquer énormément en cinq minutes et
mais
c'était assez rare de le voir secours et
tout au long d'une rencontre de manière
efficace on va dire à une belle quand
j'ai regardé quelques matchs voilà mais
je pense qu'il a un sens du panier
sais pas c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
qu'elles ont fait référence beaucoup
peut-être je suis pas spécialiste comme
vous mais avant la draft et je pense
qu'il y arrivera toujours à trouver un
moyen moment dans le match il est
responsabilisé pour pouvoir scorer et
dans une ligue où il faut répondre au
bon moment faut être là au bon moment je
pense qu'il est qui sera capable de
saisir l'occasion départemental de parcé
corones comme disait nicolas donc sont
les aspects qui qui mena mais moi c'est
vraiment un joueur que je suis depuis
très très jeune et j'ai toujours parce
que bon chiffre du sud de la france et
que c'est un talent hors pair et que
j'ai toujours dit que ça allait de
boomer et il va finir explose pas
explosé je met même en ayant cette
vision là de lui je m'attendais pas ce
qu'ils soient aussi fort aussi vite j'ai
pensé que c'est un joueur qui arrivait
en euroligue à 23 25 ans et je le voyais
pas nécessairement à une billère
ouais c'est quand même fou de se dire à
quoi ça tient une une carrière ce que
quand il parle de salon et doit signer à
gran canaria
photo bd à cinq ou six wagons canaria il
joue en équipe ii etc je ne sais même
pas si on sera on serait là réunis
aujourd'hui pour en parler s'ils avaient
décidé d'aller
effectivement il ya du talent mais il
s'est pas fait grand chose pour qu'on en
soit privé au final
et ouais les de l'exposition et
c'est vrai que
cette année là bas ça change tout quoi
c'est vraiment ça c'est game changer
après il faut confirmer et ça c'est un
autre
de notre histoire et que tu le suis
depuis longtemps parle nous un peu de la
personnalité du bonhomme parce qu'on
aime bien d'en parler envergure alors
nico a nous a parlé très bien de de ce
qu'il ya en dessous de la ceinture mais
est ce que est ce que c'est un joueur
cérébrales même en dehors du terrain est
ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est déjà dans
l'attitude professionnelle aussi quand
il répond à des questions quand tu le
sollicite aussi pour répondre c'est
quelque chose quand on est journaliste
on ressent ce professionnalisme chez
toi mais avec hugo bélanger - la
première fois que j'ai eu parce que je
après je suis en tant que joueur mais je
lui quand il était justement un sport à
chalon pour un 1er interview est ce que
j'avais apprécié c'est que
franchement il était simple mais sans
être sans le côté péjoratif de ça il
était vachement accessible et il y avait
il est jovial quoi il ya vraiment et on
en retrouve à la notion de plaisir quoi
c'est vraiment lui il ya presque moi je
pourrais je le dimanche matin et
m'éclater et il était comme ça et quand
on le suit encore aujourd'hui il a
toujours ce pays là et il se prend pas
la tête je pense qu'il a conscience du
monde dans lequel il est
vraiment il a des objectifs élevés aussi
mais il a voilà pour lui le basket il a
vraiment l'ine enfin il a été relancé
ces îles il a quelque chose c'est inné
c'est facile pour lui branchement et la
wii avec cette facilité à tous les
niveaux et ça vient de son état d'esprit
je pense entre autre oui ça vient de
l'arbre généalogique
ah bah oui bien sûr c'est ça mais je
pense que voilà il a grandi avec un
ballon dans les mains mais des fois on a
des gamins qui ont pourparlers sur les
profils de sélection on a des gars dans
ce comté il a grandi avec un ballon dans
les mains parce que pour lui c'est
normal mais est ce que vraiment il a
envie de faire quelque chose de spécial
ce ballon lui ne se pose pas la question
quand on voit qu'ils aiment ça il ya
didier cette nation et ça me fait
plaisir de voir que cette passion amène
la très haute performance ça prouve que
l'amour du jeu ça ça a quand même un
impact
essentiel dans la réussite sportive
absolument
est-ce que alors pour revenir sur gran
canaria quand même il ya un joueur de
l'ancienne équipe 2 gran canaria
la personne de jean montéro de la d2
des khalifa oui la qualification
mais il a moins joué en équipe 2 q
est ce que est ce qu on a d'autres
choses à dire sur vos vaisseaux quel
aspect de son jeu on aurait on aurait
oublié d'aborder le profil est assez
clair en fait c'est aussi ça l'argument
de vente peut-être
à l'âme c'est
c'est assez simple legault besson doit
débloquer on sait ce qu'on a y'a paille
on se pose pas dix mille questions sur
wii alors lui ou si on veut en faire un
joueur utile il va falloir que on muscle
la queue on ré angle de besson on sait
ce qu'il sait faire et a priori il sera
pas faire énormément plus
clairement c'est j'aime pas trop le
terme plug and play mais oui c'est un
joueur qui peut apporter la tacc autant
que parle du making que par le tir et
donc qui peut qui peut arriver
potentiellement à terme d'une seconde
unité en nba par le tir dans la création
en attaque sur jeu sur demi terrain et
qu'à la qualité de passe aussi pour pour
faire des vraies bonnes patients
d'origine qui est un jeu un proxy
profite beaucoup plus offensif que
défensif voilà c'est ce que je peux dire
luca est ce que tu lui mets le ballon
entre les mains ou est-ce que tu le sais
naviguer en espèces de menaces off
screen
pour pour voilà attirer la défense
toutes proportions gardées à la manière
du golden state tilly stephen curry
parce qu'on a ce débat quand même chez
envergure certains disent voir vu sa
capacité sur pick'n roll on peut lui
donner le ballon dans les mains sur une
seconde unit et il est capable de tirer
en sortie de dribble donc il va peser
sur les défenses il a créé des décalages
de y'en a d'autres qui disent il est
quand même meilleur loin du ballon et
moins - il pose le ballon au sol plus
efficaces etc soir
je dirais dans un contexte plus européen
je vous donnerai la balle pour jouer sur
pick'n roll ou pour créer ballon - mais
dans un contexte nba je le vois bien
comme disaient les dents d'un chat un un
joueur un peu au football qui peuvent
peut être un boulot de l'heure mais qui
surtout est une menace bon vent dans le
catch and shoot et c'est donc moi je le
verrai plus beau football comme qui
disait menacé après écran que cantang
londa que c'est dans ce contexte là
qu'il est peu dense un peu à la proton
pritchard
et
bonne comparaison nico est ce que tu as
un truc à ajouter sur sur notre ego
besson nationale
on a on aura une grosse pensée à un de
ses anciens entraîneurs qui lui avait
dit qu'il avait le niveau uniquement
pour jour nationale une le jour où sera
drafté
il se reconnaîtra
gabriel est ce que tu as des infos sur
ce commence pas sa tournée américaine
non j'ai pas d'inside particulier désolé
les gars de pâques pour partager non
j'ai pas j'ai pas suivi exactement son
programme mais j'y suis j'espère qu'il
tombera dans la dent dans la franchise
qui sera vraiment l'utiliser on le ça
serait un crève coeur de le voir se
balader d'aller dans les corners et
d'attendre que la balle ressorte et
d'utiliser sa son format gago droit
parce que c'est vraiment un joueur
beaucoup plus complet que ça même si
dans le contexte américain peut-être que
pour jouer sur pick'n roll et tout ça
sera encore un peu difficile mais
vraiment j'espère que que qui aura
vraiment une franchise capable de
l'utiliser sur toutes ses facettes
offensive où on peut lui souhaiter de
tomber alors
admettons qu'ils sont au second tour au
début de second tour qu'est ce qu'on a
on à orlando
d'épaisseur les raptors
sont une bonne équipe l'an dépêcha
les rapports ce picto hugo et plus vu
comme un pic entre 40 et 50 plats on a
des équipes d'être un peu alors il ya
les clippers
cleveland cependant bien que l'on
demande c'est un bon contexte pour
quasiment tout le monde
ce genre d' équipe passons au suivant
allez on va à l'opposé quoi on traverse
le pacifique
on va aux états unis michigan fac de
michigan on parle de moussa diabaté
l'intérieur qui était recruté en tant
que cinq étoiles à
cinq ans
qui n'a fait qu'une saison malgré une
cote
n'est pas annoncée rarement j'ai
rarement vu dans le top 30 dans les
modes drame
mais il a décidé de rester à la draft
est-ce que ça est ce que ça veut dire
que on avait eu il pense à l'époque 0 à
genoux retire parce que les retours que
j'ai eus sont pas ces bons est ce que ça
veut dire que les retours sont assez
bons qui devrait draft et on
verra jeudi mais c'est toujours ça soyez
à la promettre soit yann gross
vos indications comme quoi il serait
drafté soit il et il est capable
d'accepter
le tout et est donc se bat pour son spot
et peut-être aussi revenir à michigan ça
ne disait pas trop c'est par la saison a
été compliqué collectivement peut être
qu'ils prennent ils voulaient pas
transfert beaucoup beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent qui peuvent rentrer en jeu
c'est que là c'est vrai que c'était
compliqué même si michigan fait un run
honorable à la march madness
swixim
en effet tu vas
donc effectivement c'est une bonne
saison une perte d'identité
comme la faire ou pas carte d'identité
de
moussa diabaté sur internet bull
tc il n'hésite pas à aller à la bagarre
dans la raquette c'est un bon c'est un
bon rebondeur et ce que je trouve le
plus qui m'a le plus intéressé cette
année chez lui c'est déjà son envergure
de m 21 et c'est quelque chose qui
s'apprend pas donc dans ce contexte là
oui ou non c'est pas trop s'il se retire
de la draft ou ou non
peut-être qu'il ya une promesse pour
aller faire un en djelic pour travailler
sur sur son sur son jeu mais les bases
les bases sont là les bases physiques
sont là il fait a été fait de mettre 10
fin pour moi il pas encore prêt
physiquement
et il ya un peu il ya peu toute affaire
il ya beaucoup de choses à faire en tout
cas mais
est ce qui lui manque physiquement
je veux dire qu'il manque quelques kilos
de muscles pour aller vraiment dans la
raquette sans se faire
sans pour être sûr d'avoir l'ascendant
physique parce que là pour l'instant
alan e pour les boîtes noires mais
pendant la requête initiale des matous
où c'était pas lui qui avait l'ascendant
dans l'inquiète
est-ce que le souci de nous ça c'est pas
ne pas avoir de gros points forts élite
moi je n'y a qu'un seul il
développe
des pensions sur les petits donc ça fait
deux donc j'étais
moi perdre ta question ça fait pas après
je le laisserai à être développé ça fait
partie des mystères pour moi après bien
évidemment je suis biaisé je suis
français et je suis moussa avant son
départ à charenton je me suivait déjà
donc je suis assez surpris de le voir
aussi bas dans les mois mais en même
temps j'ai pas suivi autant que vous
la saison genève outre trois quatre fois
seulement donc j'ai hâte d'y être que
vous puissiez m'expliquer pourquoi il
est aussi bas mais on
nous l'a quand même un peu plus haut que
le consensus
verdure gabriel moussa diabaté alors
qu'ils ne connaissent que depuis cette
année le connaissait michigan mai mais
il ya des campagnes équipe de france
voilà il ya un pedigree d'un joueur qui
était annoncé depuis longtemps et depuis
longtemps
domine sa position à son agent
ouais il avait réalisé 1 on avait
découvert au niveau international parce
qu'ils étaient déjà partis aux états
unis est parti tôt tous les partis
nicolas tu je crois c'est en tout 14 il
a traversé l'atlantique
au bout d'un mois de compétition alors
qu'il était 2e année ouais voilà voilà
donc c'est ça je pensais à la fin de sa
saison et 14 en fait c'est au début de
la saison et cast et donc on l'a revu à
l'eurobasket hui 16 il avait fait une
plutôt une belle campagne souvenez-vous
c'était en abyme raquette très excitante
avec notamment d'année baciocchi c'était
malheureusement n'guessan quarts de
finale et il avait été encore plus
impressionnant que les u18 l'année
suivante même si la campagne avait été
décevante avec une élimination en quarts
de finale et il avait un an de moins et
je sais pas s'il avait terminé meilleur
rebondeur de la compétition mais mais
ils avaient ils avaient vraiment passé
un cap et c'est vrai que moi comme
nicolas j'ai vu quelques trop de trop
peu de matches mais j'ai vu des matches
justement il a été performant et je
m'attendais à ce qu'ils soient plus haut
mais c'est un joueur qui a une telle
débauche d'énergie fin vraiment il est
tellement intense tellement tellement il
met tellement d'engagement que je pense
qu'il pourra être utile il pourra
toujours trouver comment être utile
comme un petit peu l'opposé du congrès
sont qui va toujours trouver mon arc un
panier et là c'est vraiment on est on
est vraiment un paroxysme
voilà mais c'est un parcours qui est
très limité finalement avec l'équipe de
france ces deux campagnes après y'a le
coc vide là il était convoqué pour une
équipe de france u20 mais on se doutait
bien qu'il n'y avait pas venir là j'en
ai parlé plus tôt dans la journée avec
le staff
qui eux s'attendent à penser avec les
échanges qui n'ont pu avoir qui
s'attendent à la voir un second tour où
tout est mais il doit avoir une garantie
aujourd'hui je pense que
l'obligation d'être drafté allez vous
savez mieux que moi mais elle est
moindre donc il doit avoir une garantie
et où il trouvera un moyen de faire sa
place sur ans c'est moi je comprends pas
non plus
ça sera une question à lui poser un
intérêt à élucider pourquoi si sa cote
est assez basse parce que même les mains
tout mais voilà tu gagnes pas énormément
par rapport à être drafté au premier
tour où tu as quand même contrat garanti
et tu vas être multi millionnaire c'est
sûr même si tu es à la fin du premier
tour quoi
c'est pas du tout la même chose à
l'année ce qui pour répondre à la
question nico pourquoi est-il aussi bas
et s'il pâtit de sa position déjà
beaucoup de grands dans cette
partie du contexte michigan où il a joué
post 4 avec un poste 5 heures et
l'ancien strauss te bats qui a commencé
à ajouter sur la fin mais donc il y
avait deux mouches shooter sur le
terrain plus des meneurs de mauvaise
qualité donc là jamais été vraiment
servi dans de bonnes conditions pour
finir au serbe should remain crime y
marquer beaucoup plus sûr du rebond
offensif où il a monté directement il
n'a jamais été vraiment mis en bonnes
dispositions pour exceller offensivement
d'ailleurs voilà et c'est un genre qui
tournait à 9 points de moyenne 9 points
6 rebonds de moyenne mais c'est parce
qu'en fait il était plus jamais vraiment
mis en avant en france il ment il pâtit
aussi je pense du fait qu offensivement
il a rien d'incroyable
il a raison mais il n'a rien pu montrer
l'incroyable même s'il a quelque chose
d'incroyable n'aurait pas plus vraiment
le montrer parce que va prendre des
décisions sur short roll à la passe il
n'a pas fait vu qu'il n'y était pas
posant d'écran pour aller ensuite vers
le cercle rim run il n'y a pas trop fait
et le tir c'est un joueur qui a pris des
trois points mais qui est à 21% à 3
points sur un mois 0,5 par match donc
très peu tentative est un genre qui est
à soi à peine à plus de 60% dans ses
fonds donc le tir aujourd'hui c'est une
question c'est pas une questionnement
c'est pas un gage de de sécurité mais je
pense que le contexte n'a pas trop mis
en avant
ayem jeu quand on le voit est dans les
détails mg academy avant d'aller à la
draft c'est un
des cinq plus gros lycée des cinq plus
grosses prep school et joue avec des
joueurs nba
gérardmer robinson earl josh green
jayden springer et joue avec des joueurs
qui l'an prochain vous reste d'autres
hippiques et comme l'a dit gabriel
c'était la fête c'était l'alpha il
savait se rendre utile surtout
défensivement dans des tâches de l'ombre
l'été tâche bah allez challenge et le
box hauteur bon challenge et tous les
tirs tous les contests et tout ce qui se
passe proche du panier courir en
transition il sait je pense que sa mère
qualités offensives ça doit être quand
même là sa vitesse quand même sa vitesse
son agilité pour pour être une bonne
menace de loeb pour être qu'un qui est
intéressant en transition donc
c'est vrai que la ripelle et lé pa tro
laz outre atlantique donc
à voir parce que moi franchement en
terme de défense en switch sur les plus
petits ça fait partie de ce que j'ai vu
de mieux sur chaque hué déplacements
latéraux tout ça donc
je t'aime et tu peux en plus tu as
raison c'est intéressant parce que ce
que tu sais ce moteur s qui pâtit pas du
fait d'avoir changé de programme
quasiment tous les ans oui il a fait
deux ou trois programmes tous en flore
et de quasiment donc
pour finir amg après c'est pas le seul
on regarde de plus en plus les fêtes le
circuit lycéens ça devient vraiment
c'est assez en fait plus souvent trois
ans même dans le même ça devient un
championnat hyper compétitif il ya
beaucoup d'argent et où les grosses et
gros lycées team monte vers des
prolifiques près petit peu img type la
lumière typo qu'ils
font leur marché limite de phr agency
tous les ans donc en fait si dominer
autant c'est normal tu es ça irait mieux
sur la dernière année mais c'est vrai
que voilà j'ai lu dans un contexte qu
elles mêmes pendant plusieurs années
donc c'est vrai que ça joue la fraude à
la gemmi la charte
histoire de montrer aussi le le poids
offensif cette année moussa diabaté
michigan évidemment à remettre en
contexte comme tu le disais à l'âne avec
le stylet nucci gagnent c'est pas si
facile que ça à appréhender avec le fait
qu'ils vous avec un intérieur mais si on
compare à quoi le clan kessler qui est
pas non plus une autre
sorte de concurrents vous saviez abate
pas du même style puissant d'europe on
vous renvoie sur le podcast sur les
intérieurs mais de la draft mais voilà
c'est d'un côté on à 55% de
pourcentage j'aime ça et voir carte
escaré en est à 63 % c'est-à-dire qu'il
c'est un joueur beaucoup plus efficace
et adaptée et ça se voit oui
mais s'adapter à 70% de dans la raquette
et la part de ces tirs manqués c'est
quand on prend des tirs of the dry
belote
ou et est ce que j'avais ce qui m'avait
surpris en regardant les matchs et en
regardant les pourcentages c'est que au
final proche du siècle il loupe vraiment
pas tant que ça et je trouve que son
efficacité n'est pas représentatif au
niveau des statistiques
et où il ya
un problème de prise de décision aussi
alan moi non on peut sauter aux yeux
quand même ces jeux ces jeunes alors
qu'il n'est pas si jani lane et de la
l'âge d'être un soir
oui c'est brut oui c'est très brute
s'est dans la pression collective sur
demi terrain il peut faire des passes
mais il voit pas la passe avant la passe
sinon ne sait pas toujours le bon
décalage il faut vraiment que les gars
soient ouverts avec les mains comme ça
qu'ils lui fassent mais c'est pas
négatif parce que c'est un leurre de 19
ans à qui on va surtout demandé je pense
ou débuts en nba steve wynn biais de
faire durer one vraiment on va le mettre
en avant menace de loeb mais c'est ce
qui limite aujourd'hui son arsenal
offensif parce que
le processus d'appréhension et et est
assez lent
nico est ce que sur ce genre de position
on peut quand même espérer des
développements
non il ya dix-neuf 19 ans et demi et six
mois
est-ce qu'on va vraiment lui demander
d'être un créateur
créateurs mais au moins
à bâle et dante
pour l'instant c'est sa limite
effectivement c'était je pensais que
c'était uniquement les matchs que
j'avais regardé mais de ce que j'entends
de l'année apparemment ça a été
comment dire tout au long de l'année
donc oui c'est une limite c'est vraiment
un pour moi pour l'instant c'est son
atout on en a parlé gros rebondeur
défense switcher
être mobile portier du cut
réduit certes mais sur la passe pour
l'instant c'est même le qi la lecture et
la compréhension du jeu il aura
énormément de travail est à faire et en
même temps c'est un intérieur qui arrive
avec une formation moitié français
moitié us et les intérieurs us ils
arrivent généralement pas non plus avec
un gros qi un gros bagage technique
c'est quoi la la ligne à suivre à la une
danielle ghafour
verrouillable robert williams était plus
dans le côté honneur on en avait parlé
capable
disait daniel gagnon est plus vraiment
switcher
ford michelle robinson un peu plus petit
et surtout d'europe mais ouais un jour
un joueur qui peut être l' uci draft
pour être un backup rim runner et que
j'ai ensuite tu peux développer dans
d'autres aspects de son jeu le tir ils
en prenaient pas mal sur début d'année
il en a mis quelques-uns
je parierais pas encore dessus mais je
pense je sais pas c'est juste que je
disais que l'expérience se coltine
report je pense que c'est pas la chose
la plus importante et la plus importante
c'est qu'ils puissent quand j'étais
petit écran finir fort au cercle et
améliorée sans qu'on peut sa
compréhension sur pick'n roll et shorts
robes ça ça pourrait vraiment
c'est pas un produit fini loin de là
mais par contre le les outils de base
qui là ils sont déjà vachement
intéressant c'est pour ça que je veux
donner par pas la place qui va
le quand tu parles d'outils de base
c'est vraiment le cette rapidité pour un
intérieur c'est de ces changements de
direction et elle est mais voilà son
sens du rebond
puis bon la mentalité aussi je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui avait qu'à une canne
un parcours atypique cas qui a été
refusé deux fois par le paul gauguin
pardon pour des raisons scolaires
essentiellement
ouais j'en connais d'autres qui sont
entre poule avec 4 de moyenne donc voilà
on peut se poser la question mais un peu
à la manière du gobé son jeu les eu j'ai
dû la voir quand il avait au tout début
de son parcours aux états unis parce que
justement il est et 1,5 connu en france
et j'avais été frappé par l'humanité est
pas la foi sunnite et puisque je les u23
fois depuis
il se voyait pas du tout arriver
vraiment et c'était son objectif
quelqu'un de très ambitieux mais
comme valeur refuge le travail pour tout
le monde tout le monde sort aujourd'hui
oui je passais des heures dans le
gymnase je suis un gros travailleur mais
mais vraiment j'étais assez surpris pour
un gène qui avait eu ce parcours un peu
alambiqué et qui était partie des états
unis je pensais qu'il allait être un peu
justement parce par tous ces refus opole
s'en servir comme une pas comme une
excuse mais avoir un sentiment de
revanche n'ont vraiment lui il a tenu à
revenir à chaque fois en équipe de
france bon c'est arrivé deux fois mais
c'est le contexte qui l'aurait empêché
de le faire plus souvent elle était
alors qu'il aurait pu se concentrer sur
la campagne et ue
voilà je trouve que son jeu correspond
vraiment à qui son état d'esprit quoi
c'est quand même d'abord vraiment je
pense quand même c'est un col bleu on
peut attendre de lui qui prenne en
l'espace de trois minutes quatre cinq
robots a vraiment sur des séquences où
il est très engagé
après il ya vraiment tout à faire et
aujourd'hui je faut pas se cacher je
pense qu'il aura beaucoup de temps à
passer en j-league au début mais il est
très très loin de son potentiel et c'est
vraiment pas un produit fini et comme
les et nicolas metal et il peut être il
peut être très utile dans des équipes de
très haut niveau voilà il ya une qui a
le x 59 et qui n'a pas peur de
développer des joueurs ont-ils x et
portland
hans erni symons et qui l'a fait aussi
avec nasir little
world race pc profil un peu brute comme
on dit peut-être une bonne destination
pour moussa directe et galerie aller
sur mornant ça
c'est un joueur il faut qu'ils se
construisent encore physiquement et je
pense qu'il est capable de lisser son
niveau en allant plus haut donc pour lui
c'est intéressant de d'aller se frotter
à nba et des joueurs qui vont être
qu'ils vont le dominer tout simplement
même sur ce même sur ses meilleurs
aspects sur ses points forts et je pense
qu'il va travailler fort pour
pour ce rapidement se mettre à leur
niveau mais
voilà c'est
là pas peur du challenge et ce sera
intéressant mais faut pas en attendre
trop trop vite
le matériau de base et la holding
je m'inquiétais pour le look as qu'il y
avait un problème de facture
d'électricité
n'hésite pas on est là on t'entend qca
ouais j'aime j'ai allumé la lumière g20
ont pu faire une montagne un petit truc
cinéma c'est pas mal
balisé qui vous êtes jeune et
belle à la parole en plus d ôter au
centre dans mon écran je sais tout
le gouverneur s'est offert
tout cas ce que tu as il ya quelque
chose que tu avais noté
moussa non j'ai rien à rajouter sur
moussa mais j'avais une question posée
est ce que du coup ça il fait partie des
styles de cette sorte des joueurs qui se
pend drafté en fin de second tour et qui
ont la chance de faire pas une carrière
qu'on n'attendait pas forcément
moi je pense qu'il a une chance de
l'être ça dépend toujours du contexte
lan je pense qu'il est là l'opportunité
que ouais mais ses idées quand je trouve
que deux joueurs ou je peux être apte au
second tour et quand même avoir ta
chance tourner ni holender les bonnes
normes le chant choral ce sera un super
meneur bas que non second tour ça marche
pas souvent malheureusement et meilleur
marqueur nba c'est des mecs des choix
drafté en l'autre hymne des ou des
choses comme ça
en creux métaux ayant un rôle comme vous
le poste de back pivot d'intérieur au
troisième inter d'une rotation avec les
attributs physiques qui lasse on arrive
à leval e spécialisé sur une ou deux
choses que pour moi faire faire carrière
qu'est ce qu'on doit travailler le plus
vite chez le médecin
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'ils prennent
encore 5 10 kg et
c'est sur ses points forts il peut pas
se permettre de de ce fait un bep il
peut pas se permettre d'exploser
justement quand il vint fort rebond
il peut il peut déjà apporter à une
équipe mais à condition d'être au niveau
et sur sur ce à quoi et puis ça se fait
vite un une bille et même aux états unis
d'une manière générale donc mais
justement
lui il y est déjà est-ce que d'habitude
on 17 soit par exemple pour kamagaté
andy bogard ben il va à prendre l'avion
il va il va atterrir il aura déjà prédit
kg mais lui c'est ça fait déjà trois ans
il doit le faire mais pas trop parce
qu'il va perdre sa qualité de ses
qualités principales de sa mobilité dans
l'espace et qu'elle n'a et donc je pense
qu'en fait
pour moi c'est c'est peut-être la passe
ou le tir parce qu'en fait ça pour leur
âge là on voit ça pourra permettre de le
faire qu'il ne sera pas tension pas le
seul nos shooteurs son terrain et qui ne
sera pas transmis singh
en fait ça permettra la route qu'on
comprenne est-ce que c'est nos shooteurs
sur le terrain où est ce que il fait
partie des tireurs parce qu'en fait ça
limitera sa polyvalence il faudra le
mettre avec un type de l'intérieur
spéciale à côté donc je pense que le tir
même si je veux pas qu'ils travaillent
que ça que ça que ça je veux pas que ça
fasse une ibaka
même si c'est très bien sûr unima cas ça
sera quand même quelque chose que je
vais regarder ce qu'il en prend en ses
murs ligue et ce qu'il peut en mettre
dans l'année prochaine chez dignité
nico tu n'as fait une transition
fabuleux pourparlers d'ismaël kamagaté
va être notre notre prochain prospère
français vous côté du paris basket cette
année luca j'ai décidé que ce serait
présente nous et cela dans les points
forts déjà en fête bon on fait ça dans
nos podcasts m'ont dit c'est quoi son
ticket d'entrée dans le théâtre
son activité je dirais et surtout sa
qualité à protéger le cercle qui qu'il a
continué à travailler cette année avec
avec paris
et surtout ce qui ce qui m'impressionne
c'est ça la capacité de travail
il ya à dire il ya trois ans il était n
à orléans où il ya 80 est là aujourd'hui
c'est il pour magistrate au premier tour
son activité sa et son éthique de
travail elle est quand même elle est
quand même à noter et surtout un sens du
rebond qui est impressionnant et qui
s'est développé au fur et à mesure des
années c'est un joueur qui il ya deux
trois ans je pense que à la même manière
que besson de parler lui comme un
prospect billets ça ça aurait fait ça
fait rigoler
et
l'instinct si ces cérémonies il a des
difficultés à créer pour lui-même même
si cette année on avait des bons flachau
aut post-up
le dunk on a un peu tous vu contre
contre levallois et il a montré vraiment
des bons flashs mais je pense que ça
quelle entrée cesson sa capacité à
protéger les êtres un backup center
entrée
être être une menace mettre une foire
sans défense est allé terminer pour le
du cercle
un complément à l'âne
franchement non très très compliqué
comme je rassure un secteur est vraiment
comme un peu sur besson
l'aspect sous côtés de toute sa carrière
chez les jeunes parce que génération
2004 elle par l'intérieur de cet euro et
18 en 2019 il y était aussi kamagaté
mais c'était le back up de
diabaté et j'avais noté dans son soutien
report il avait très peu joué il n'avait
joué que 75 minutes en six matchs donc
il était un peu sous sous-évalué mais en
fait ça fait
trois ans voici le site
je te fais un bémol répondu après je
pense que c'est totalement différente
besson ou kamagaté il est vraiment
arrivé sur le tard à 1 si on était
vraiment
dire que c'est ce que je veux dire c'est
jour de génération 2001 qui était pas
labellisé comme des vrais les meilleurs
de leur génération c'est juste un média
et qui pourtant aujourd'hui ont un
ticket d'entrée pour la nba via la
drogue et je pense que personne n'aurait
pu le dire il ya quelques années sur ses
pédales mandature sur une génération une
donnée il ya toujours il ya toujours des
fenêtres qui sont différentes et il ya
des profils de joueurs qui vont être à
16 ans et on sait on sait aujourd'hui
que sur les 2001 à l'époque on savait
que il y en avait qui étaient peut-être
40/50 et qu'ils allaient remonter et
d'ailleurs chéri s'inverser et kamagaté
sur 7 euros effectivement j'avais noté
la comparaison entre les deux s'est il
est il est et il peut certes il n'avait
pas beaucoup joué tout mais c'était un
de ceux qui intrigue intrigué beaucoup
parce que les autres quelque part on les
connaissait quoi il y avait peut-être
kaz allan où on se disait bon bac à quel
point il va pouvoir être performant
surtout quand grouille la hiérarchie
c'est lui qui devait prendre le lead vie
qui avait pas assez mal et dont mais
c'était le début de l'aventuré très haut
niveau pour moi kamagaté il ya l'arrivée
il avait fait sa fameuse saison à
orléans et l'année d'après il était oui
ou basculer en pro b mais il arrivait de
n3 kan s'est dit tiens et on essaye on
commence à en entendre parler dans le
papa ou dans les médias le large mais on
va dire dans le milieu l'hymne national
ces dix mecs vraiment qu'est ce que
qu'est ce qui peut faire et puis depuis
deux ans il a depuis trois ans du coup
il n'a pas du tout déçu
oui clairement je veux dire c'est
familial il y avait pas rit avec et sans
lui quoi
et puis même face à une raquette comme
monaco je sais pas si vous aviez vu le
match à bercy où paris était vraiment
limité un secteur intérieur et on a
l'impression que paris était presque
au niveau de monaco avec kamagaté est
clairement en dessous sans kamagaté
qu'il y avait des soucis de fautes et il
arrivait quand même à jouer avec son
engagement à 4 fautes défendre à quatre
fautes face à des joueurs de top niveau
européen qui pour une fois était de par
le contexte
intéressé par le championnat par un
match du championnat par le fait d'être
bon et donc
donc du coup c'est plutôt sur un match
deuxième partie de saison et oui c'est
un joueur qui qui qui a fait comprendre
qu'à paris avait pas besoin de deux ans
au pivot us que c'était parce qu'ils en
avaient déjà un joueur de gros impact
pour le championnat
certaines personnes qui ont des intérêts
il ya des pistes pour lui en fin de
premier tour
du monde
alors la comparaison avec les autres
joueurs de de la la je vais pas vous
mentir je suis pas un spécialiste là
dessus
il avait du monde
ah oui oui d'accord oui non mais il a
été placé toute la nba tout au long de
la saison on arrive à un point où c'est
je veux dire c'est ce serait une
anomalie qui a piqué personnes bon
c'était c'était pas aussi c'était
peut-être pas aussi reach va y avait
évidemment vectorman manama mais c'était
pas y avait pas trente mille personnes à
suivre en cette saison donc le passage
obligé en plus à paris fait que ya
maintenant qu'ils se détachent la
lisibilité est difficile je vais pas
vous mentir ça fait une bonne douzaine
d'années que je suis dans le milieu bon
à chaque fois que tu changes avec les
agents ils vont toujours te dire ouais
de toronto ils l'aiment beaucoup par
pour telle et telle raison et puis jour
j ai l impression que ça suit parce
quand à raconter
je me rappelle même de du jour où on m'a
vendu negueba samake comme au premier
tour à dallas je sais plus mais c'était
donc ces gens n'arrivent loin mais je ne
sais pas je dirais rien de concret qui
wizeo ce niveau
c'est pour ça que la plupart des modes
draft sont généralement jusqu'au
classement un petit peu éduquée mais
avec des infos
avec plein dans lequel il faudrait
ajouter de nombreuses *
la comparaison à faire je dois tous les
deux en championnat
ll est avec makoun ou qui est plus vieux
ya un ou deux ans plus un en plus
un beau et et non non et puis peut-être
les deux kamagaté a quand même plus de
plus d'années de basket de pratiques et
moi je trouve que au delà l'âge ya aussi
cet aspect qui rentrent en ligne de
compte et même si kamagaté il a changé
complètement physiquement 16 17 ans donc
je sais pas si ça mais ça lui ça amène
quand même quelque chose au niveau son
cursus basket et
le poste qu'elle cherche foyer et ça ça
mais ça t'amène quelque chose quand elle
a été retrouvée à jouer plutôt post 3 tu
bascules sur secteur intérieur en
mobilité tesson en dextérité des fois
même tu es censé pouvoir avant un vrai
gain que
luca il ya une vraie différence en
protection du cercle déjà pour commencer
pour demande premièrement aux intérieurs
entre
clairement pour moi c'est même si le
profil de you and
me me laisse pas de marbre mais pour moi
c'est vraiment deux joueurs qui jouent
pas du tout la même cour
surtout dans la protection de siècle
makoun doit montrer bon flash de
protection de cercle mais pas à aller
jusqu'à en faire sa qualité principale
alors comme il est plus bondissant
et c'est là qu'on voit
la vo là c'était une réelle volonté de
la part du stade de paris ou de kamagaté
je sais pas mais deux d'avoir cette ce
rôle de protecteur de cercle parce que
je sais qu'ils ont énormément bossé sur
les timings avec lui
donc je pense que
makoun doux avec le potentiel pour
devenir un mais que kamagaté les
entreprises et makoun doute plus dans un
profil qui devrait être décalé au poste
je trouve trop
pas assez imposant et impactants pour
être un poste 5 heures soit 1,1 en
janvier ou en europe
alan q tu es d'accord sur le contenu et
la peep a raison sur le jeu offensif
peut-être qu'elle est là la différence
entre les deux est locale elle a un
profil je dirais plus facile à adapter
pour les exprimer
la juste défensivement que quand la
différence elle est surtout là comme à
gâter ses puces intel core 2 drops pack
windows pour moi c'est un romer c'est un
genre de second rideau
lecture un peu
tour de contrôle qui va à nier toute
tentative au cercle à l'égard du coup
parce que leurs moeurs c'est un rôle
projeté souvent mais là il n'ya pas
encore mais il a tous les attributs
physiques athlétique pour lui faciliter
la vie là-dedans en fait offensivement
c'est différent c'est parce que ma
coundoul tir bas coûts même si je suis
pas très fan de la mécanique des gars de
makoun goût c'est quand même 58
tentatives à trois points cette année
avec cholet pour 34% de réussite c'est
pas atroce un joueur qu'à progresser aux
lancers francs qui est maintenant à 77%
dans cette foire qui était à 66 % l'an
passé et pour tous les intérieurs qui
tire à trois points c'est quoi c'est
surtout je piquais une pop ou
ou du simple ketchup quand il est
c est rien de compliqué mais c'est plus
en exécutant du système qui peut se
retrouver avec un tir à trois points
continue un peu oublié ou sur pick'n pas
tandis que ma kamagaté pour moi un
excellent finisseur proche du panier
66% je crois aux tirs cette année 70 %
l'an dernier en pro b ses cheveux si je
fais pas l'erreur donc très bon
finisseur qui prend pas de tir extérieur
qu'à un tir parce que quand je regarde à
l'échauffement prendre mes distances aux
lancers francs ça décolle pas trop des
60 5% ce qui est un peu décevant donc
makoun ou plus tireurs sur pick'n pop et
tour de contrôle défensive romer
kamagaté drop et finitions au cercle
dijon un petit peu parler d'idées et du
coup qu'est ce qui est le plus recherché
selon toi
je pense que le profil de kamagaté est
plus
répandue mais par contre il le fait il
le fait tellement bien et il a tellement
bien fait dans un contexte professionnel
sur longue durée que c'est quand même
plus c'est un peu plus recherché que
mathlouthi
romer et stretch c'est un projet pour un
genre qui en plus pluvieux donc je pense
que c'est plutôt kamagaté
ok on manque d'abris excuse moi rien à
voir avec les royals profit techniques
mais on est à parler de moussa diabaté
là on parle des semelles kamagaté johan
makoun 12 quand même trois joueurs n'ont
pas été au pôle les trois joueurs qui
ont des profils vraiment vraiment et des
parcours très atypique
absolument tous les chemins mènent à la
preuve venez
d'où un mas jean moulin quand même 1
précise que c'est pas souvent qu'on peut
parler de basket de haut niveau et de
monein
est ce que quelqu'un ait quelque chose à
ajouter sur sur nos deux camarades
avant de passer aux ordres nationaux
makoun du mâconnais workout quand on
voit un peu sur les raisons il
n'a qu'une douche fait avec le spi singh
en nba fait des demandes je pense qu' il
est sur le chemin pour développer son
tir mais au-delà de ça il peut vraiment
vraiment profit des il va y va il va se
régaler dans l'espace en nba on l'a vu
sur le match contre l'asvel il a
vraiment développé et des you step et
les déliés il peut finir enfin vraiment
c'est en plus de ses qualités physiques
de finir très fort il peut finir on sent
qu'il aime sortent plus il a développé
cet autre aspect spectaculaire dans son
jeu ils ont des fois l'impression qui
part d'un des horoscopes la dgi nobili
je mens je m'emballe un peu mais mais il
ya une fluidité -
ouais voilà je vois pas comment elle
paraît il n'arriverait pas s'exprimer
puis puis franchement c'est un jour à
gérardmer je suis pas un mec qui me lève
de ma chaise mais je me rappelle je sais
pas s'ils avaient d'autres personnes ici
qu'il était mais c'est un stage où il
n'y a pas beaucoup de monde en u18 gelé
découvert contre la sélection u17
justement à 2001 et en l'espace de dix
minutes il a mis 4 dingue
stratosphérique mais incroyable
découvert ce joueur ce jour là et eux et
il va y va au delà de l'aspect
efficacité de s'imposer sur le plan
sportif il va se faire connaître aux
etats unis c'est pas possible qu'ils
finissent pas régulièrement dans le top
ten
n est ce que c'est le je te mets
meilleur meilleur dunkeur de cette draft
y at il des chats et chiens car c'est le
chemin de chars qui a
éliminé dans la liste higuain est dans
là il est dans la liste des joueurs
extrêmement spectaculaire fait ken
talbot peut-être
peut-être challenger n
harrison mais c'est un phénomène
athlétique et c'est un phénomène
bondissant ça qu'il faut dire c'est que
il ay la fille s'est fait lever la
meilleraie la salle de cholet plusieurs
fois cette année absolument à caen à
quand un concours de dunk et de thirau
une vieille compagne on s'amuse un peu
plus tôt qu'ils prennent des tirs
ouverts
gabriel merci beaucoup de nous je
remercie
merci pour l'invitation les gars merci
pour votre travail
allez bonne fin de soirée merci beaucoup
gabriel donc de basket ceux qui
connaissent des connaissances de basket
en france connaissent 10 basket c'est
quoi les prochains contenus rapidement
parce que qu'est-ce qui est prévu
prochainement vous allez suivre la drac
oui bien sûr c'est sûr mais là il ya la
finale lmb évidemment qu'ils encourent
en a on avait une équipe à à
villeurbanne en a une à à monaco et on
espère qu'on aura une série avec des
matchs serrés un peu même s'il ya un
partout et voilà et bien sûr la draft et
surtout la coupe du monde u-17 je serai
à la coupe du monde u17 du 1er au 10
juillet ça va être vraiment intéressant
de suivre cette génération superbe
merci gabriel la prochaine
ciao
on passe aux internationaux et vu qu'on
était sur les intérêts ni gauche de lens
direct
est-ce que ismaël kamagaté ça vaut
khalifa diop
oh la la ah oui alors
physiquement
[Musique]
kamagaté on est dans
un truc un peu un peu déliées un peu
élastique khalifa diop on est dans de la
pierre on est dans du
domaine minérale
moi je pense qu' il faudrait me donner
beaucoup d'argent pour que je rentre sur
un ring ou dans une raquette pour
essayer de me taper avec avec al issa
diop et baal et on lance une cagnotte
allez-y pour aller pour 8000 euros je le
fais
avec outhwaite jobs sait on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé alors je t'avoue que
c'est pas celui qui est le plus regardé
cette année parce que dans le registre
de ce que j'ai pu voir j'ai pas vu
énormément de progression ne ça reste
pour moi et allen et luca et toi de me
contredire pour moi c'est vraiment du
rebond contre écran
relais pour moi il ya toujours un
problème de touché et le toucher ça
s'achète pas donc du coup c'est un peu
compliqué alors c'est la tempête dehors
là c'est les aléas du direct je vais je
vais fermer la porte et je reviens de
suite
luca khalifa diop
est ce que est ce que pour toi tu on
parlait tout à l'heure des différents
types d'intérieur en billets toi tu
ferais défendent plus en drop est ce que
mme romer peut-être contredire mais est
ce qu'il peut pour quoi être assez
rapidement efficaces dans ce rôle là
c'est quand même un joueur quel un vrai
plan du jeu
donc il ya un réel problème en défense
une sorte de naïveté
ils haïssent haute énormément énormément
sur le sueur sur la balle du coup on va
dire que pour un contre faire de 2 5
fautes et je trouve que vraiment ce but
justement la plus marquée en regardant
et
donc pour moi en me laisserai personne
défenseur un peu à la kamagaté mais
faudra vraiment faire un gros travail
sur le timing de contre parce qu'il a
les qualités a détruit que pour être un
protecteur de cercle mais il ya cette
question de timing qui rentre un enjeu
comment comment expliquer que la autant
de temps de jeu dans une ligue aux excès
compétitifs s'ils avaient des vrais
problèmes de protection
vous posez la question à la volée un
moment et son temps de jeu c'est ça oui
parce qu'il avait quand même un bon
temps de jeu dans une très bonne mais
c'est alors tu vois autant avec kamagaté
tu peux faire un pari sur le sur le
potentiel autant avec khalifa je pense
que c'est
le plafond n'est peut-être pas très
élevé mais le plancher il est il est
stable c'est que tu sais ce que tu vas
voir tu vas voir un gars solide qui va
poser des écrans qui vas tu as fait pour
l'équipe qui va qui va user ses
adversaires parce que parce que comme je
te le disais pas physiquement s'il faut
se le coltiner ya une activité et du
coup
entre qui leur est jamais déçu quoi
qu'est ce que tu vas voir
parmi tout le
lot des pivots internationaux qui sont
là je vais mettre la liste dans le petit
bandeau en bas le lesquelles
lesquels vous plaisent le plus pose à
chacun la question et avant je vais je
vais les cités il ya une chose à eelv ou
badges et donc khalifa diouf dont on
vient de parler et carlo matkovic et je
crois que je crois que j'en oublie pas
allez-y et je vais la liste
est longue
bah moi c'est vrai que ça dépend ce que
tu cherches si tu cherches de du poteau
du potentiel soit disant du potentiel tu
vas sans doute préféré il voulait être
gêné kenzo ça si tu préfères
du plancher tu vas se référer tiapé
matkovic la pma de comics qui sont deux
joueurs qui ont un rôle dans une
rotation d'une bonne ligue européenne
elle nie gars assez bnd à la meilleure
pour john malkovich avec mega cette
année et même l'année dernière et joseph
meyer en liga la chine ligue adriatique
se sent donc s'allier qui vont avec des
clips des clubs de bosnie de croatie et
de être servis badji année sosa
d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce qu'on me
l'a encore joe pesci dans le même débat
ça fait quoi que ça fait super longtemps
qu'on les deux sont dans la même
question parce que ses deux intérieurs
de la génération 2002 du sénégal et
qu'on a vu dans les équipes de jeunes
jouer ensemble des fois tellement parce
que nos clubs ils jouent ensemble de
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
joueurs à mettre sur le terrain
quasiment dès fois donc c'était c'est un
peu compliqué pas être jn ce sont des
phénomènes athlétique je pense qu'il
faut dire que pense que c'est les jours
dans l'année le rapport taille
jump et vitesse ne sont pas normales
juste ses joueurs qu'ils ne peuvent pas
voir le t1 aujourd'hui en pro en europe
parce que dans les lectures et dans le
déchet offensif c'est trop pour une
équipe qui a des ambitions ou ont pu
être donné les clubs de diop et matkovic
donc baky c'est un organigramme du barça
donc c'est à dire l'organigramme du
personnel je disais dès lors la base les
analystes n'a il a en fait je veux dire
le barça et ses clubs satellites quoi
il leur
revient paul saint lyé da voilà on y est
allé donc en neige qu'il est malade
c'est la deuxième un ouais c'est la
mongolie en 2e div et malaga il fait du
hibou badji c'est à dire que sur le
papier
tout le monde signe mais quand tu vois
jouer il manque un truc c'est
transformer les mensurations du goût
badji parce que ferris et de m 16 être
de mettre 35 d'envergure pour 105 kg et
la vitesse en l'air et tout droit assez
incroyable honnêtement
mais la menace d'un lob parfait fois ci
c'est tout fonctionne c'est jordan mais
parce qu'un bon
mais je vois une équipe faire le pari il
y en a il y en a il y en a une qui va
faire le pari parce que parce que sur
papier c'est trop beau c'est trop gros
du coup il ya toujours ce côté hockey
avec eux avec le barça n'a pas marché
avec moi je dis non je suis reprendre
voilà moi je saurai
boîte à questions moi c'est matovic du
bois où tu sais de quoi non non non je
sais rien sur sur badji mai mais si
j'avais un billet à m ouais je pense que
je pense qu'il va se faire drafté et ou
alors si je peux pas drafté il aura un
tout et contracte mais je ne vois pas de
retour en europe est
drafté draft et
lui vivent là il faut il faut je sais
pas il faut
phone électrochoc avec lui parce que
parce que les latitudes parce que les
moments d'absence sont trop gros trop
énorme et je suis sûr qu'il ya un staff
qui va vouloir prendre le pari et se
dire qu'est ce qu'on a à perdre
physiquement il est monstrueux si on
arrive à lui donner deux trois
manu kitai d'autres si on arrive à lui
donner deux trois fondamentaux en
attaque on peut on peut faire quelque
chose et puis il a le physique pour
finir à la tacko fall chouchou de sur
instagram et sur twitter parce que le
moindre contre qui va mettre ça va être
ça va être incroyable oui
juste avant de donner la parole sur sur
markovic
à la nouveaux cas je vous laisse parler
je parle beaucoup
enzo ça
a été longtemps la blague avec avec
ramoné et nico
de montrer sa tête à d a déjà un dire
quel âge at il et souvent les réponses
sont entre carentan et et 35 ans donc
c'est compliqué donc et un
dessin du coi
après pour qu'on pour expliquer la
blague la blague elles sortent du du
club de malaga parce que ils ont fait
une vidéo pour son anniversaire ou tu
entends un espagnol les joueurs se
[ __ ] de sa tronche en temps mais
arrête dit on voyage tu as 30 ans et une
vidéo qui est resté une journée sur une
soirée sur twitter qui a été au coeur
parce que tout le monde à partir de là
ils sont dirait si même ses coéquipiers
il se moque de lui il ya vraiment
quelque chose
pour moi le problème des noces à c'est
son sa qualité aux robots de son sens du
rebond et c'est quand même
impressionnant qu'un jour de cette
taille soit seulement 2 rebonds 2
rebonds de moyenne en ac b et donc pour
moi c'est un réel problème pour sa part
ils sont habillés
je le vois pas
peut-être qu'une franchise sur al paris
mais pour moi je le vois pas vraiment
d'en poser
le des dents quelques années en nba
mais
c'est sur le papier parce que moi je
cherchais beaucoup de matches pour le
voir en fait tu ne vas pas parce qu'il
joue pas ça le problème en début d'année
je vois un petit peu
il mettra dix minutes de moyenne mais
plus la saison avance et moins il joue
aussi c'est ça aussi qui est un peu
coûteuse pour les matières sait qui il
est inégal trop négatif pour ce nouveau
type sont en fait plus pour progresser
sur le terrain mais je n'avais qu'à des
problèmes d'anticipation rebonds il ya
tout qui a fermé encore une fois c'est
ça peut être un joueur à scouts parce
que badji et lui ont des physiques qui
sont mes incroyable enfin je serais
quand même moins impressionnant
physiquement at il dit mais il est quand
même très bon dix ans mais il est le
moteur là pour faire les allers-retours
le riz brun à fond ce avec le vraiment
le faire donc pour moi enso saïd bahaji
pas vraiment être drafté un deuxième
partie du second tour les équipes qui
veulent faire paris randy quoi les gars
il ya un an enzo ça c'était le black
pour coup c'est ce qu'
il était notre hippiques j'avais chez
tout le monde c'est n'importe quoi il a
il a pas de tir il a pas de dribble prêt
physiquement c'est super intéressant oui
mais ils m'ont quand même beaucoup de
choses donc par contre si c'est si l'ap
a retiré son nom faut être clair c'est
qu'il va être drafté parce que de 2003
il a tout à perdre à se présenter à pas
être drafté sicile a pas enlevé son
c'était là une promesse
voilà ça c'est l'affirmation de nico
avant la publicité pour
mega mozart
mon chouchou voilà
le plus vieux du lot
oui mais plus pluvieux en termes de
dates de naissance officielle par contre
physiquement c'est un vrai l'aigle aux
mains c'est un gars qui a grandi
tardivement cadets main énorme qui
athlétique qui a un qui a un super
voleurs qui peut protéger le cercle j'en
parle c'est attention c'est pas il va
pas être drafté un numéro 7 numéro 10 ça
va être sûrement un deuxième tour mais
là où je dis mon chouchou c'est parce
que c'est un joueur que qu'on a commencé
à suivre des l'euro 2016 à un monténégro
et qu'il a joué avec la bosnie mais il
sera international croate
et c'est pas c'était pas un joueur qui
était coté c'était une grande asperge
vont se disaient pas trop ce que ça va
devenir et c'est en fait c'est ce qu'il
est devenu cette année l'an dernier qui
ont fait moi je la serre mais un des
joueurs que j'ai préféré regarder en
plus je suis obligé de le dire comme
youssouf n'dour kitsch papa policier
donc je ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont c'est
parce qu'ils mangent les papas en bosnie
les papas
mais c'est juste je sais moi j'ai pas
envie de me battre avec la police en
bosnie c'est j'imagine même pas les
profils physique qui doivent avoir bref
je joue pour l'instant c'est pas un
joueur qui est capable de s'écarter de
tirer au loin
par contre candidat pour être le seul
nom tireurs sur le terrain oui tous les
jours et je vous dis avec un
développement physique je parle pas de
comparaison de jeu mais je parle de
comparaison de carrière je me dis que
son nom m'échappe intérieur
clippers et aux lakers au rang des
balkans en revanche vous bac merci voilà
me dit un parcours à la efficace du
match c'est à dire arriver sur la pointe
des pieds en nba se faire sa place petit
à petit et puis au gré d'un très doux ou
d'une progression finir comme étant le
post 5 je parle de ça dans 5 6 ans 7 ans
mais je me dis qu'il a vraiment le
potentiel pour même si si je devais
mettre un billet sur lui je le vois
superdraft et puis partie est restée
moins un petit stage baran alors
particulièrement grave je fais la
réflexion de faire une moc droite il ya
beaucoup d'équipés avec beaucoup de
choix
et donc au bout d'un moment ils vont pas
pouvoir intégrer tout le monde va y
avoir des des européens ou enfin des
internationaux
de dire heureusement on n'a pas de
maître kovic
enzo saint
gilles gassama
pavel surf
spagnolo pour moi ça c'est des joueurs
qui vont être drafté qui vont sachez
alors parlons avant de parler de cela
peut-être des profils en un peu moins un
peu moins connus on va parler quand même
de la tête d'halliche nationale
on oxea nuit c'est nicolas jovic
jovovich
loca est ce que tu peux nous écrire pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais dû jouer
c'est un award 2008 2011 en turquie il
ya une
gare un pourcentage à 3 points correct
mais est elle qui est pas unique où on
sent que ça prendra du temps a et qu'il
devienne un leurs élites en nba mais
c'est un joueur qui
peut être ben maintenant mais qui pour
moi ne pourra pas être un banc l'heure
ni n'diaye mais c'est 1 500 watts et
kaka une vision de jeu parce que on l'a
vu il fait quand même des passifs qui
sont impressionnants pour sa taille mais
il est capable de venir au cercle et son
gros problème cette année ça a été au
début de la saison il s'est retrouvé à
défendre sur des postes extérieurs dont
des cartes etc et ça a été vraiment
compliqué pour lui parce que dans la
latéralité c'était impossible de suivre
donc c'est pour ça a été pour moi ma la
plus grosse interrogation au niveau
défensif mais de la même manière que
pour ousmane ning et au moins c'est ça
se travaille pense pas
devenir un et peut-être grossier mais
entre indie
dans le rôle parce que je vois pas dans
quel rôle il pourrait se retrouver dans
une rouste
nikolaïevitch alan
quel rôle il peut avoir en nba est ce
que la question génie c'est ce qu'ils
voient un top 20 il est peu évoqué à ce
niveau-là de la droite et pourtant c'est
un joueur jeune qui a déjà
quatre tickets d'entrée assez clair avec
avec son tir est une expérience
pour moi sont extraits de ce sport c'est
instructif alonso nba un genre qui
apporte du space in qui peut aussi par
delà la peur qu'on a dû s'y reposer un
dribble sur klose out et ensuite prendre
une décision parce qu'il s'agit là cette
formation de porteur de balle on a vu
que la servie par exemple voilà plus en
19 langues il était passé on a vu
capable de prendre des décisions je suis
une diesel sera trop dur pour lui de
faire ses actions mais par contre s'en
tire son bras feront tout pour moi un
vrai bon joueur de rotation une vie et
je pense que m un très bon très bon
stretch fort et en défense ne pas le
faire défendre le porteur de balle comme
le dink a peut être des petits porteurs
de balle d'américains du championnat
dégainez latics ont vraiment fait un
enfer latéralement il ya vraiment
beaucoup de mal à naviguer les grands
organes hausse mais je pense que
je pense que son tir est une assez bonne
un assez bon ticket d'entrée en couple
et un bon point mais king pour un quart
de lui en vendre assez dans le top 35
niko je me lance sur l'ailé
le caractère du monsieur parce que ma
mine de rien c'est pas pour faire des
général et serbes non mais il est mort
des balkans il ya l'art et du cochon
et ben lui c'est la tête de cochon
c'est typiquement l'école des balkans
c'est à dire que rocco ou pas
franchement au début non sur les sng tc
rocco numéro 1 toutes catégories mais en
devenant pro rocco s'est calmé et de
l'autre côté nos vies tch c'est un peu
transformés en a j'ai du mal à en tic
ont
ils fait deux maîtres d'hier lutte de m
on vous l'a dit un grand mais mais ouais
ça son dernier passage sur les finales
ngt insupportable
tant de gueuler sur tout le monde
c'était devenu le leader de l'équipe est
en fait c'est faut savoir que c'est
culturel quoi faire que dans les balkans
appartement où c'est toi le leader de
l'équipe c'est un coup de gueule sur tes
coéquipiers c'est toi qui décide de
sortir quand tu veux donc nous ça nous
fait toujours bizarre non en tant que
français un doigt on aime les joueurs
disciplinés qu'ils respectent les les
allées les coachs et c'est là là bas
c'est puisque room attali et puis je
coure matelly et & company et donc du
coup
sur le plan du caractère et c'est sûr
que en termes de caractère il en a
voilà c'est le genre de joueur qui peut
très bien
se battre lors de sa première année
rookie parce qu'il en a marre que les
ricains le prennent pour un mec soft et
qui le prennent un peu pour eux pour le
petit bouffon du coin quoi donc c'est
passé pas négatif je trouve que ça fait
partie du jeu de yoyo kitsch de jovic
parlant c'est c'est quelqu'un qui qui a
une haute estime de lui-même qui a
beaucoup de confiance et qui joue avec
ça après sur le tir match est moins
positif que que mes deux collègues je
trouve qu'il n'ya pas une progression
que ces mêmes la limite aujourd'hui on
parlait avec luca dans l'après midi
pourquoi ousmane dieng lottery pick et
nikolay au beach annoncées fin de
premier tour bah pour moi c'est les
promesses sur le tir qui sont dits sont
différentes après l'année djokovic a été
vraiment dents de scie il ya eu des
moment même où on parlait de ne pas
mettre son nom à la draft parce que va
pas montré suffisamment sur le terrain
moi quand je peux pas parler de lui sans
penser à roko père thaçi alors
effectivement je vous en parlais au
niveau du caractère cerqueux rockhopper
catching deniev dia diouf dit 'je crois
moi je les voyais vraiment comme des
loteries pic en puissance donc c'est
vrai que c'est c'est la galère
à diyala et et oui père caché ne le sera
pas y'avait-il le sera pas a priori donc
selon alors c'est un peu bateau ce que
je veux dire j'enfonce des portes
ouvertes mais selon où il va atterrir ça
dépendra beaucoup de sa carrière
c'est je pense le type de caractère le
type de joueur à qui on peut pas lui
laisser juste cinq minutes et une toute
petite place dans le vestiaire il va
falloir le faire d'abord
le caractère qu'on en fait quel est ce
qu'il ya une différence entre ceux qui
ont réussi mais en nba des new kids
j'avais les murs kitsch bat et
plein d'autres qui finalement ils sont
allés où ils sont même pas
ce qu'ils vont plus tard aussi
c'est quand même là de plus en plus et
yvan plus tôt
je voulais dire la différence de
caractère nico s'est passé
avec mon âge avancé peut-être que je
suivais debias et prospère
ouais
ce match non je suis passé à côté
en termes de caractère je te dirais que
les en général les têtes de l'art ils
ont jamais fait une les têtes de l'art
que moi j'ai pu voir évoluer en jeunes
du côté des balkans c'est pas eux qui
ont fait les plus grosses carrière c'est
plutôt des joueurs
vu que je suis passé à côté j'ai posé
beaucoup de questions sur ce match et et
c'était plutôt un joueur discret un peu
un joueur ben intérieur nous en dominant
dans les balkans tu poses des écrans du
rôle tu prend des rebonds et tu fermes
ta gueule donc du coup quand tu arrives
en nba c'est plus facile de s'adapter et
de dreux sa place parce que tu étais un
soldat jovic jeu ça peut l'être après il
est jeune on tombe sur un coach qui lui
explique les choses correctement qu'à
l'habitude des européens c'est sûr que
s'ils tombent sur sur
mon pote de philadelphie doc s'ils
tombent sur doc rivers car pas un mec
ultra fan des européens qui a jamais lu
trop envie ce s'adapter à ce qui
pourrait être différent je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il fera une longue carrière chez
les sixers mais
dans des franchises qui ont une culture
un peu plus européenne avec le temps
voilà la question que j'ai envie de vous
poser c'est qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le
jeu de yo vide qui pourrait l'empêcher
de faire une très bonne carrière en nba
son physique
je suis maintenant ça devient un petit
peu près il a tellement pas de
latéralité ou de qualité verticale qui
peut pas défendre soi mais les moniales
et lee child web bellic à vue il a
concédé des mois c'est une des mes
compagnons je pense
à
moi me fait penser à me rotich ouais
j'ai eu très chaud ouais on y cite c'est
tellement fait pourrir ces derniers
playoffs
et puis je pense que bobby portis y est
aussi pour beaucoup non
on lui souhaite de pas rencontré les
phalanges de bobby
opportuniste faisait manger sur les
switchs c'est ça que je veux dire il
était visé c'est pas possible il ya des
plumes était un âge plus avancé venir
aux tirs je ne sais pas quel âge ils
viennent ils vont arriver à 24,8 ya
vraiment pas de
latéralité quelconque parce que là vous
l'avez vu comme des petits garde véloce
qui sont trop petits pour jouer en nba
bonjour mickels réa tic
moi je pense qu'il pourra garder des
quatre pape a gardé deux manières élite
en tout cas pour les 2 3 ans à venir ce
n'est pas un joueur qui se retrouvera
sur le terrain pendant les minutes qui
comptent
bien voilà c'est dit là et puis en fait
on présentait quillanaise est déniée
exacte des prospects offensif et
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus des
prospects défensif et qu'il y aura un
impact défensif dans la vie car elle vit
notamment des mines qui est c'est à dire
excellent défensivement et je
m'attendais pas du tout donc il ya
peut-être aussi physique ils sont pas
les mêmes et dénis le faisait avec le
maccabi en euroligue donne il faisait
déjà honnêtement je demande je crois que
j'ai commencé à avoir joué qu'il y en
ait dans l'ue 15 ont honnêtement la
première fois que j'ai vu défendre c'est
cette année puis avec l'épisode serait
relaxée en avant avant on a vu le
contexte on a eu le contexte reliques
pour déni était un peu différent en fait
que richie a toujours un contexte où
c'était soit lui soit soit un autre mais
tu es deuxième créateurs on n'a jamais
vu par exemple si tu avais déjà clos
partisans en eurocoupe aussi la venue du
joueur avec le
l'étoile rouge en euroligue là il aurait
dû avoir ce rôle peut-être de juste
restauré m'aider et défend voilà jamais
eu vraiment défendre ce long voyage
beaucoup beaucoup de minutes en ligue
adriatique
sauf peut-être avec l'équipe nationale
où il a il a eu parfois ce rôle lui qui
a été dans la fenêtre fiba en tant que
stretch fort défenseur mais là c'est un
échantillon de 3 88 pas suffisant
nikolaïevitch donc ont conclu sur sur
lui puisqu'il nous reste un paquet de
nom a évoqué et là je vais faire appel à
tata capacité de concision nico il va
falloir présenter ses les profils
venir et ensuite on va où bas vous allez
chacun de donner un petit peu votre
votre chouchou parmi parmi ceux là alors
nous traversons dit traverse l'ex
traverse nuque longue très costaud
physiquement
kolb le joueur d'effectifs
broken shoot aucun tir avant c'est
atroce
mais il a les qualités athlétiques de
de notre ami olam est sûre le
l'australien du tas bien évidemment john
dryden alors reviendrait
il à portland c'est vrai maintenant donc
dans un rôle de joueur de collectif dans
une équipe il y a que des shooteurs oui
sinon en gros si tu veux que je continue
les eaux troubles a dit mme annie médias
protides à la grosse cote européenne de
ces dernières jours le choc le plus
joyeux de cette draft des qualités
athlétiques incroyable par contre il
fait 15 kg donc ça sera un rôle player
je suis sûr qu'une équipe nba va tenter
le coup parce qu'il ya du duncan
robinson quoi il ya du tiger heroes vous
n'êtes pas non john duncan robinson
puisque tu as donc voilà à suivre matteo
spagnolo grosse cote
il a le meneur de jeu pardon qualités
athlétiques formé au real
costaud vraie gamme de tir il a tout
pour pour évoluer en nba mais en même
temps s'il va pas ça sera un des
meilleurs joueurs en europe et c'est un
gros fan de basket il a une grosse
culture basket il est possible qu'ils
retournent real madrid le milan est déjà
dessus il a un bail out à 1,5 million
d'euros donc
voilà à suivre et les deux derniers donc
ça m'a réservé kof voit la promesse au
deuxième tour c'est selon leurs agences
et actés igas a marre c'est un meneur de
jeu à l'ancienne de grande taille mais
qui est vraiment faible je parle de
force physique
qui joue pour les autres donc lui doit
ça ait pas un tweet de jonathan j boni
ski ski ski quand même fait peur un peu
sur le rôle de certains scouts nba qui
attendre que j'ai connu ce tweet pour
ses intérêts c'est un gars ouais ça
s'appelle un petit message
perso ça me fait flipper ça
donc ouais joue dur compétiteurs mais
bon zéro dunk cette année quatre contre
sur une saison pour moi c'est vraiment
profil et orly et sait comment ils
servent l'année dernière il y avait un
gars un peu comme ça un peu augmenté
mais coeur
polonais
un polonais
albert celui de paix retrouvée du
retrouvez donc découpé donc un grand
meneur mais pas assez athlétique
pourquoi pour effet 6 x trail
gaza main
ensuite pavel sivakov c'est un russe le
joa la culture de khaled tu parlais de
calais des actifs ou quoi non
on n'a pas droit de parler
ils peuvent elles savent que c'est le
jour le plus soft de toute la draft
c'est la base konya
c'est un bosseur il a un beau tir mais
il peut pas défendre donc pareil je
pense qu'il a tout pour être un super
joueur d'euroligue qui sera drafté à
profit la faire deux trois ans puis est
retourné en europe
1 vient donc d'en dans tout ce que tu as
i télé les deux plus évidentes sont les
italiens pour un rôle ans et demi oui
même si au quotidien il était 8e homme
dans son équipe qui jouait le maintien
donc en termes de contexte c'est
vraiment un contexte
joue en italie il joua entoure il était
content tout avant et là il était à
bologna n'est pas dans la grosse équipe
à lourdes par la gauche et à fortitudo
est donc en fait le contexte était
vraiment dégueu lui le combat il me l'a
sauvée parce que les gens ils sont dix à
temps ses toiles il est grand il est il
à la tête au cercle il
il un vrai qualité de tir et lui en fait
on lui demandera jamais de poser un
groupe vraiment on va le mettre dans un
corner et puis on pourra l'utiliser
comme ça donc maintenant il faut il va
falloir 5 10 kilos de muscles et il est
possible qu'il reste un nom en europe
encore pour voir comment ça se développe
mais mais mais en tout cas un vrai
profil qui monte dans le côté du côté du
côté de la
sidr sa cote et elle est assez forte
lalanne et doit être que tu as un
chouchou parmi ceux là alors le chouchou
de nico ses looks traverse mais on a
bien compté qu'il croyait que
moyennement moi c'est moi c'est un
joueur qui est auto éligibles c'est une
grosse trifunovic non je rigole c'est
gratuit c'est une blague
il ya au dos et l'egypte c'est un
2010 et prend des mythos partisans oui
c'est hurler dessus par obradovic mais
dans ces plots cheese à prendre parce
que prod chine a en fait c'est
plug'n'play
dans une franchise qui travaille bien
qui va prendre sa qualité de tir la
mettre en avant et masquer un petit peu
et d'efficience dans le reste du jeu je
pense qu'il faut voir où je pense que
mon préféré c'est spagnolo que j'adore
matelas de l'eau avec des équipes de
jeunes du real c'était vraiment énorme
avec crémone cette année en 1re division
italienne c'était super intéressant
aussi mais je pense que athlétiquement
il peut pas être assez fort bon moment
pour qu'on lui donne et c'est sa qualité
principale tandis que je produis d'aaa
le tir le tir les qualités athlétiques
en boule pour vraiment on se relâche par
les rassure produisait même si j'aime
beaucoup spagnolo nous pas
sûr c'est sûr sinon là je vais pas à
d'autres pour bazire en parler son sens
réellement inventé mais j'ai juste vu
dans ce mois juste traverse donc un peu
mon choix par défaut mais papa je crois
pas énormément
au vu de deux sons de son côté physique
un peu un peu average il a rien
d'exceptionnel physiquement comment
c'est un bon joueur mais je le vois pas
dans un contexte lié équivalent maillot
chez ans du côté de la bête
quatre d'entre eux fut court mais pour
compléter ce que vient de dire luca en
fait
physiquement il est très costaud c'est
juste athlétiquement il est vraiment
moyen c'est du coup c voilà le
professeur remets tes lunettes quand tu
fais des combos cabu l'air attention
donc alors oui quatre trios david brent
brain ne sais pas il est plus éligible
en tout cas elle va faire la summer
league à phoenix mais il est déjà à
chicago il est il est dans l'équipe
jerid à chicago
avec les soldes c'est pas du programme
il a dit qu'il allait s'envoler vers
les états nuit mafieuses je lui ferai un
bijou de votre part à las vegas a
vraiment absolument puisque ce sera du
côté est ce qu'on a oublié un oubli guy
santos qui est candidat c'est bon
je peux pas vraiment vous en parler je
pense qu'ils alertent grands et costauds
quoi
ouais je les ai vu jouer il joua bel
horizon qui est une superbe ville que je
vous invite à voir si vous passez par le
brésil où les gens sont très
sympathiques maintenant ça n'en fait pas
ça n'en fait pas un prospect biais et
l'historique alors les équipes jeune
brésilienne fonctionne bien en ce moment
mais lui il faisait chaud qui nomme
finale de la coupe de sonia rykiel est
ce pour ça on est mais en revanche lui
il faisait pas partie de la génération
brésilienne qui était que ces fameuses
en hausse mais voilà c'est un format
énorme et moi sur ce que j'ai vu j'ai
pas beaucoup vu
non c'est pas mon dit voilà dix lousada
j'y croyais à tort visiblement je
croyais de santos pas trop mais il a un
vrai beau nom brésil santos ça fait
classe dans l'effectif
est-ce que vous est ce que voilà comment
commence qu'on parle et les jeunes
français si je t'avais lancée là dessus
nico pour pour plus pour la blague en
comparant diop kamagaté mais pour
revenir sur les intérieurs dont on
parlait tout à l'heure au niveau au
niveau de la copa de la cote mais de là
l'intégralité en nba
comment tu vois ça toi là ne laisse que
est-ce que makoun doux kamagaté ont plus
de chances d'y arriver que diop mccaw
chose un super bonne question je
touchais kamagaté suis calcul de chance
pour deux raisons il ya une chance de
quoi de se faire drafté et d'y rester
ces deux choses différentes 2 / a
draftés oc kamagaté parce que il ya une
certaine forme de avec une progression
d'année en année donc le championnat pro
problèmes publics élite un rôle majeur
qu'elle a dit quand il était là quand il
n'était pas là c'était papaye basket
d'ailleurs c'est une chose que j'ai
vraiment apprécié et ses qualités
principales qui prenait pas un autre
faute est en fait mais jeudi à
l'intérieur se venge en prennent
beaucoup et il n'en prenait pas trop
donc c'est bien et aussi tirer aussi
parce qu'il savait que j'allais pas qui
n'en prennent trop parce que sinon
s'arrêter grâce à rémy en difficulté
après pour jack matkovic marc quinn do
direct matkovic à une bonne année bonne
cote parce que les images de son pro des
ans un peu impressionnés mais il a eu la
chance d'y aller au bout voilà il a fait
son pro des 100 agences salaire de
pernod met en avant il devait retirer
son nom finalement il le laisse et ça a
changé en l'espace d'une heure ou deux
pour moi ça veut dire qu'il ya peut-être
il ya quelque chose derrière diop moi
j'aime beaucoup je pense que c'est un
joueur assez sûre et tu peux tu peux
aller à mâcon nous est le plus vieux de
tous donc je pense que l'âge ça compte
aussi
alex tu l'aimés tu es sur la même ligne
moi je mettrais quand même malgré tout
l'amour que je porte à ian mc do je le
mettrais quand même bien en dessous des
3 autres en termes de cote ok ok non
mais je veux c'est pour ça c'était idiot
annoot silwan attrape un tour et
contracte ça serait déjà super bien
est-ce qu'on a est ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a fait le tour est ce qu'on a fait
le tour est ce qu'on a des questions que
j'ai oublié dans le
coach aurait fait surprendre en disant
que peut avoir un joueur auto et
l'egypte qui va être drafté s'arrêtent
quasiment tous les ans ouais donc là on
serait normal n'aurait peut-être donc ce
serait les 2000 et vous avez des noms et
2001 j'essaie d'y penser franchement
j'en ai pas énormément j'ai dit griffin
au but pour la blague mais non mais ça
arrive que ça arrive assez souvent donc
on verra bien ouais bon en tout cas il
est 23 heures j'avais dit a promis qu
qu'on finira à 23h et si pour une fois
on peut finir la leur eh bien ça sera ce
sera tant mieux merci à tout le monde
dans le chat pour votre participation
vos questions
et même parfois votre programme de la
soirée
avec énormément d'altruisme merci luca
pour ta première tu allais les
félicitations du jury
on attend là la deuxième du coup avec
impatience
plein de choses à dire cet été
pour moi le seul 2000 qui a une chance
c'est balseros qui
prolonge
en 2011 ce qui me grand et lourd
oui jo el para je vois le par à
l'espagnol
une grosse cote non mais c'est pas mal
parce qu'on l'aimé on l'aimé en tête et
comme ça on pourra dire bah oui on vous
l'avait dit quand même avec trois
secondes à la flanc
merci à toi florian d'avoir d'avoir tenu
tous live avec des noms que tu ne
connaissais pas voilà on a fait voyager
aussi en australie même brésil afin
d'être prospère africains des prospects
européen
était pas mal merci nico ça faisait trop
longtemps au bien être du plus vite
on va on va faire des trucs dupuy sera
là à la summer league on va se prévoir
va se prévoir un petit programme pour
pour avoir envergure made in usa depuis
depuis las vegas
et puis à l'année ben on se retrouve
chez la first team pour prendre acte et
je pense simard dit et là je pose la
question en direct
mardi soir tu es là on faire une foire
aux questions donc je serai là on va
répondre aux questions diverses et
variées on essaye de faire des contenus
pour répondre à mesure mais enfin on
peut pas ne pas être sur tous les fronts
même si voilà vous avez plein de
podcasts à disposition je pense qu'il ya
pas mal de quoi écouter on a beaucoup
condensé cette année on n'a pas trop ça
charbonneau sachar bonne pas mal un
dernier big board à sortir une mode
draft idéal comptera peut-être en direct
mardi est donc tout ça tout ça pour nous
mener à jeudi soir merci tout le monde 2
avoir suivi et on fait des bisous et mes
3 pouces bleus